using the i guess we could call it the
washer method or the ring method we were
able to come up with a definite integral
for the volume of this solid of
revolution right over here so this is
equal to
the volume and so in this video let's
actually evaluate this integral so the
first thing that we could do is is maybe
factor out this pi so it's going to be
equal to pi times the definite integral
from zero to one
and then let's square this stuff that we
have right here in green so two squared
is going to be 4
and then we're going to have 2 times the
product of both of these terms so 2
times negative 2i squared times 2 times
negative y squared times 2 is going to
be negative 4
y squared and then
negative y squared squared is plus y to
the fourth
plus y to the fourth and then from that
we are going to subtract this thing
squared
we are going to subtract
we are going to subtract this business
squared which is going to be 4
minus 4 square roots of y
plus the square root of y squared is
just going to be y
and though all of that and then all of
that
d y
let me write that in that same color
all of that d y and so this is going to
be equal to this is going to be equal to
pi
times the definite integral from 0 to 1.
and let's see if we can simplify this we
have a positive 4 here but then when you
distribute this negative you're going to
have a negative 4 so that cancels with
that
and let's see u the highest degree term
here is going to be our y to the fourth
so we have
we have a y to the fourth i'll write it
in that same color
y to the fourth and so the next highest
degree term right here is this negative
4y squared
so then you have negative we do that
same color
we have
negative 4
y squared that's that one right over
there
and then we have this y but we have to
remember we have this negative out front
so it's a negative y
so this one right over here is a
negative
y
and then we have a negative times a
negative which is going to give us a
positive 4 square roots of y
so this is going to end up being a
positive
4
square roots of y and actually just to
make it clear when we take the
anti-derivative i'm going to write that
as 4 y to the one-half power
and we're going to multiply all of that
stuff by d y
now we're ready to take the
anti-derivative so it's going to be
equal to pi
times the anti-derivative of y to the
fourth is y to the fifth
over five
anti-derivative of negative four y
squared is
negative
four thirds y to the third power
anti-derivative of the negative y
is
negative y squared over two and then the
antiderivative of four y to the one half
let's see we're going to increment it's
gonna be y to the three halves multiply
by two thirds we're gonna get eight
thirds
plus eight thirds
y
to the three halves and let's see yep
that all works out and we're going to
evaluate this in at one and at zero at
one and at zero and lucky for us when
you evaluated zero this whole thing
turns out to be zero so this is all
going to be equal to pi
times evaluating all this business at
one so that's going to be one-fifth
minus four-thirds let's do that green
color
minus four-thirds
minus one-half
minus one-half so whenever you evaluated
one it's going to do so plus
eight-thirds
plus eight-thirds
plus
eight-thirds and let's see what's the
least common
multiple over here it's a five a three
and a two looks like we're gonna have a
denominator of 30. so this is we could
rewrite this as equal to pi
and we could put everything over a
denominator of 30.
one-fifth
fifth is six over thirty
four thirds is forty over thirty so this
is minus forty
that's the different shade of green well
actually let me make that other shade of
green so this is
minus 40 over 30
negative one half that's minus 15 over
30
minus 15 over 30 and then finally eight
thirds is the same thing as 80 over 30
so that's plus 80
plus
80. so this simplifies
to so let's see we have a let's see we
have 86
minus let's see 86
minus 50 finally actually make sure i'm
doing the math right over here so 80
so
80 minus 40
is going to get us so if 80 minus 40
gets us 40 plus 6 is 46
minus 15 is 31. so this is equal to 31
pi
over 30. i have a suspicion that i might
have done done something shady in this
last part right over here so this is
going to be let's see negative 36
negative 51
plus 80.
i think that seems right i'm gonna do it
one more time let's see 80 minus 40 is
40
46 46
minus 10 is 36 minus another 5 is 31. so
yes we get 31 pi
over 30 for our for our volume